with us in Florida hate Tom welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave how are
you better than I deserve sir what's up
kind of a two-part question number one
is my wife and I went through your
program about five years ago but we
didn't have kids in and we have three
now and we were newly married non-fire
and things kind of you know went by the
wayside and here we are we've got some
you know about eleven thousand in credit
cards
eleven thousand in student loans and
about forty thousand in a vehicle and
we're getting to that point where it's
like okay this isn't cool I'm spending
more than we're spending more than we're
making and I'm a lonely person that
brings in any income so looking for how
intense should we be because I feel like
we may be on two different pages I'm an
all-or-nothing type the guy will rip the
band-aid off and eat beans and rice and
no but you're not you're not gonna
you've not been doing that
well I haven't no but that's where I'm
at right now that's what I want to do oh
and you know I want to deplete or
account and pay off our credit card you
know cuz I have we have enough to pay
the credit card off right now what's
your household income 160 okay well I I
you know there's a concept in
Christianity called repentance yeah and
it means when I'm walking towards stupid
I first stop and then I do a 180 and I
walk directly as fast as I can
away from stupid I change directions
okay yeah and you know and sometimes
repentance for me has been it was
something stupid I knew better than to
do that I know if a chocolate chip
cookies I get big as a house I know
better right but sometimes I reach a
point where I say I've had it and I have
to stop and I have to turn 180 and go
the other direction
it sounds like mental
emotionally that that's where you might
be but something occurred in the last
few weeks that didn't occur six months
or eight months ago with you that caused
you to start thinking that way all right
yeah I think you know honestly what it
is is a lot of our friends you know live
by your principles and have I mean you
could we can just see the fruits and a
lot of people and it's you know going
through it five years ago you know we
were debt-free and you know but I mean
you went bought a $40,000 freaking car a
stunt well I know and that was yeah I
know and so you know we put uh we put a
new AC unit in a few weeks ago which
fortunately you know we had the money to
do yeah well you make really good money
if I were in your shoes I'd be disgusted
that I was just broke as much money as
you ma'am I am and so what now we've
kind of talked about you then you you
asked about her my point is is that you
probably have had some information or an
experience that she hasn't had so to
assume that she's going to
simultaneously turn and do the 180 with
intensity the way that you are thinking
you are going to without the same set of
information without the same set of
motivations without the same why that
popped up in front maybe you're doing
the bills that she doesn't feel any
stress from them maybe you're feeling
the stress and you may need to get her
to look at the bills with you can make
her feel stressed out like you are
because you ought to be hmm you ought to
be you ought to be disgusted and
stressed and a couple of other things
that cause you to want to change yeah
but it's unfair for you to snap your
fingers after you just got this epiphany
because both of you were walking
hand-in-hand stupid for four years yeah
and then you just decided to stop and
turn and you're shocked that she didn't
so you know you you it's not just
band-aid off you've got information and
motivation from outside influences and
sources that she does not have or she
probably would have turned to so my
suggestion is for both of you to go back
through the class
and say honey we got to relook at this
we make too much money to be this broke
this drive me crazy I think we ought to
get some of stuff paid off I want to
look at it again I want us to work on
this together and we can decide together
what we're gonna do but together we need
to go back through financial piece and
look at what jounin Jim over here did
and look at what this happened and and
you know it didn't take the first time
we flunked we got to go back
you got to repeat the class we flunked
it and no shame in that the shame would
be as if you'd never woke up obviously
been more efficient to do it the first
time but it's not unusual for some of us
to have to do things over most of us
have to I'm pretty thick it takes me a
couple times to get stuff sometimes so
so are you so give it another run you
flunk the class grab her by the hand say
honey I don't have this figured out but
you let me figure it out and let's get
back through here let's start looking at
this again and I think when you go back
through Financial Peace University
you're gonna find it to be a completely
different experience than it was five
years ago considerable upgrade nowadays
oh man we have spent a lot of money and
a lot of time on that thing since five
years ago
so yes the principles are tried and true
but the process we used to teach you is
so much more efficient so that's what I
would do if I were in your shoes